I recently took my kids to a special
movie theater by where I live movie
theater is special movie theater has a
cafe it has a bar but what makes this
particular movie theater special is
everybody they hire has a disability
every employee of this movie theater's
got down syndrome
head injuries diseases
wheelchairs you name it they got it and
guys I gotta be honest the service was
incredible it was better it was faster
they were old school ripping the ticket
enjoy your show sir and I was amazed by
how much better and faster it was
because how many times we were at a
regular theater looking at the people
behind the counter thinking this guy
[__] [__]
I don't know